sexting is a crime oh my god
uh we thought we thought the uh the big
news this week
was gonna be that there's sufficient
evidence inside the manhattan da's
office that the current manhattan d.a
who was just elected alvin bragg will
not act upon
that donald trump has committed several
felonies
that which he could be held fully
accountable
by definition from the assistant the the
the special assistant district attorney
former
pomeranz
that was supposed to be the big [ __ ]
news
it's gonna shake the earth
and then yesterday bob woodward and bob
costa
the bob's as it were bob and bob
bobo and bobby
break a story and the story goes like
this
jenny thomas
the wife
of the supreme court justice clarence
thomas you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] box
the one the one vote to make sure
that the january 6 records of donald
trump didn't get in the hands of the
select committee
hmm seems suspicious now that's that's
suspicious
the one vote clarence thomas his wife
jenny thomas
is a [ __ ] q another
i'm not [ __ ] you it's not just it's
not just for me it's not just that she
was trying to help donald trump
commit
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
from from the bedroom
of a supreme court justice
you're telling me that clarence thomas
didn't know
that that jenny thomas was seditiously
sexting
mark meadows that's what i'm gonna call
it seditious sexting i don't give a [ __ ]
that's what we're calling it here
think about this
you telling me that clarence thomas had
no [ __ ] idea not one goddamn clue
that his wife jenny thomas was in
communications with the chief of staff
of the office of the president and the
united states the white house
and texting him crazy ass chewing on
[ __ ]
crazy ass queuing on [ __ ]
this isn't like she was like oh
mark please make sure the president
knows
that we're all here to support him even
though he lost and we think he won nope
nope
this is straight up
[ __ ] whack-a-doo my pillow nazi mike
mike lindell
traitor mike flynn the kraken sydney pal
q and on [ __ ]
the cult
it's a [ __ ]
cult who said it a hundred times here on
this show i've been saying it for over a
year it's a [ __ ] cult
and jenny thomas the wife of clarence
thomas the supreme court justice
the thing that
really catches me here is in one of
these [ __ ] sextas sex messages
these seditious sex messages that she
sends to mark meadows
she says the elites are trying to keep
donald trump from being the president of
the united states or some [ __ ] like that
she
she thinks that there's other people
more elite quote unquote
i guess in the political sphere i have
no idea what the [ __ ] she's talking
about
then the wife and the supreme court
justice and the white house chief of
staff
and supposedly the the
blue collar billionaire the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants
the president united what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you're all [ __ ] ivy
league educated
you're all [ __ ] rich you're living in
washington these people are absolutely
[ __ ] delusional the cheese has slid
off the cracker
and we want these people to be in power
of anything [ __ ] anything in this
country these people shouldn't be
running a [ __ ] cash register for for
crying at the bigly wiggly for crying
out [ __ ] loud
these people want to not only be in our
government they want to control it
i would say if clarence thomas and
supposedly he has left the hospital
which seems a real [ __ ] convenient
for the timing of all this
too bad infection didn't win that
[ __ ]
resign or impeach i think that we need
to know what that [ __ ] knew we
need to know this country needs to
[ __ ] know what he [ __ ] knew and
when the [ __ ] he knew it
did he know that his wife was was
was seditiously sexting mark meadows
cueing on conspiracy theories
about how we have to overturn the
[ __ ] constitution and the election
the duly elected president joe biden
and by the way
by the way
the reason why
that jenny thomas didn't want joe biden
to become president
is because she's a [ __ ] racist that's
right i said it
everyone beats around the bush here
because she's married to a black dude
remember the black dude that she's
married to that's the [ __ ] that's the
trope i got a black i'm married to a
black man i can't be i can't yeah you're
married to a black dude
that wants to ostracize black people
from society
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
if they had their fascist state ways
clarence thomas
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know i
don't know what chief justice roberts is
doing this morning but he should really
be [ __ ] evaluating whether the
supreme court has any more legitimacy at
this point his court is is literally
four [ __ ] members of his court
four
the one whose wife he was seditiously
sexting mark meadows the chief of staff
of donald trump who was trying to commit
his cheeto dust kangaroo coup overthrow
the constitution of the united states
which by the way jenny thomas has taken
a note to as a lawyer
by the [ __ ] way
neil gorsuch the first [ __ ] pick of
the of the cheeto dust mobster
brett kavanaugh who was bought and paid
for the same way as they rammed amy
coney barrett down our [ __ ] throat
because she's paid for four of them four
on the court four
are illegitimate at this point
i'm just saying if there's a reason that
we would need to reevaluate the supreme
court as
as one of the most qualified nominees in
the history of nominees
is going to be confirmed because joe
manchin has said he's a yes on her
because there's no other reason why he
can or cannot be if if if
if brown jackson would have gave manchin
a reason he might have considered it but
he didn't and the only reason why we
only need mansion here the only reason
why is because of mitch mcconnell so all
you [ __ ] you trump humping fools
gonna whine and complain lindsey graham
josh holly tom cotton ted cruz you [ __ ]
are you gonna be whining and complaining
and bitching that she gets confirmed
it's because of you ramming supreme
court justices down our throats
i've been saying this for days that
there's
that the supreme court here with these
these hearings with kbj
and now we have clarence thomas's wife
jenny thomas
caught
wide out in the open that she was
seditiously sexting mark meadows to try
to overturn the constitution of the
united states overturn your vote
jenny thomas wanted to take away your
vote because she didn't like how you
decided the election
they're always talking about freedom and
and and liberty and all that [ __ ] they
don't [ __ ] have any goddamn idea what
liberty freedom our rights even are
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty
and you jenny thomas
are a [ __ ] traitor to the
constitution
and to our country
you are a treasonous piece of [ __ ]
because you wanted to overturn the
rights of other people to duly elect the
president of the united states
that's what you did
that's why it's so [ __ ] disgusting
jenny thomas or anyone out there who's
gonna defend her dumb ass
the other thing too
is that mark meadows wasn't just
receiving text messages this
[ __ ] was sexting back he was
seditiously sexting back
over and over again talking about this
is a fight versus good good versus evil
you goddamn right it is you goddamn
right it is it's a fight ver good versus
evil we do not want a fascist state
that's why we elected joe but i don't
believe
that 81 million people voted for joe
biden
there was a hell a lot of that 81
million that voted against fascism
they voted against
trump
they voted against trumpism
what they did
81 million [ __ ] in this country
and jenny jenny thomas thinks that she's
she she thinks they're the 81 million
are the elites
oh a [ __ ] elitist
an ivy league educated
wife of a [ __ ] supreme court justice
thinks the 81 million people that voted
for joe biden are the elitist you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i use that word for marsha blackburn but
god damn
that word is becoming more and more
appropriate this week
for these seditious bastards
thank you kathy for the super chat as
you guys know
we have super chat now and not to switch
switch gears all of a sudden
we have super chat now on the youtube
chat board
you can
contribute to the show thank you kathy
very much for the super chat we really
do
we really do appreciate it here and we
appreciate you guys joining us if you're
new listeners out there we're on every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch and now on the
midas touch facebook page as you know we
are we are proud partners of the midas
touch
organization with the mizella's brothers
ben brett and jordy
thank you fellas for helping us out and
partnering with us
uh we we love we love uh
having you guys here with us um whether
you're on facebook youtube twitch or
twitter
we love having you here
and today is a special day not because
not just because we get to uh
to completely destroy jenny thomas and
clarence thomas
um but because it's bonehead of the week